ええっはいん
やばいつまりでさずにそうです体調悪いっていうか風邪なんですけどね書いてゆけです
ねるるきゃんてあげる見たんですけども
キャンプしたくなりましたというわけで骨が買ってみました
ただキャンプするだけだとあれだと思ったんでこれすごいんですよキールテントあの僕
の実家の話なんですけども結構家族みんなキャンプっていうかバーベキューとかそう
いうアウトドア系が好きなんですけども
ラボ
2月の半島で逆にインドアになってしまいました理由とシェアまぁ色々あるんですけど
も
キャンプとかバーベキューって結局準備とかものが重いとか寝ござ吸ってるんですよ
まぁそこがよさっていうのがあるんですけども僕は精度ちょっと苦手だったので結局
インドアの人間になってしまってるけどゆるキャラ3体キャンプしたくなってしまい
ましたアーキー0点取ってことは盲点と運ばねっ
いいでしょうねわからないまだ実物見てないんでなんとも言えないんですけどスクが
天井になるって事はあっ
[音楽]
どういうことだけで買ってみましたあけてみましょう
あーあちーさゆるキャンで見たやつだ a 徒歩でこれしか入ってないんですよ
はいなんかはこれしか入ってないんですねこれでできたらまずやばいよこれこれ食べ
てんの作らの骨組みにあたる部分なんでしょうね
例えばにことポネ組はいるらしいんですけどこれ以外に入ってるもの
これだけなんですよ猫
でキャンプできるんだったら俺やるよ
まずどういうことは全然わからんぞでわかんないよ
いますなぜなにすればいいと思って頑張ってみれば個人的にやってるけど多いの苦手な
んですよねどっかのサッカーを開けてとかそういうのすごい苦手なんですよね
わからない1チップ10 base blog チャー月
雪平車載
うわっ
うわっ毒牙を開けろって書いてるんですけどねモンキーの感じます
箱ガンダム方向を開けて
おっ待って見えた meet me ターン軍でここあげるの買う
[音楽]
あっはぁうほ4どう見てもデブやツアー1
からまあまあを張ってこれきたぞこれは完全にただこれすごい
どうでしょうはい町議の若干ハリーポッター家はあるんですけど結構温か s ちゃんと
服っぽくなってると思いますねすごい愛でも全然素敵だと思いますなんか候補者
レイナー服ありそうですよね山登る1面の女が起きたらすごい可愛いきますか俺が着る
とバケモンですねはいたけど問題はここからですこのれが検討作れるか道化そう
が問題ですよ外で頑張って点灯さんの作ってみました
やってゆるキャンで見たねっても大丈夫あのホタテに作れるんだったら俺でも作れる
はず
誰でも楽しめるそれがキャンプですねまず線と思っていく手間が省けるのはまずでいい
と思うんですよね
あー点灯作っていきましょう
どうする頑張ってみるん
マジではからどうやって例えば完成ですん
me
まぜっ
思い出した点とってくるの難しいんだったーー
はぁ
w 怖いへ本当に find やばくねこれ大丈夫
こんなキャンプある山平抱かなくになるとか踏まねば
あさんのはないと会えないん
そういうやり方ですあっちゃー
ええええええん
ブーンわかりましたわかりますわかりましたわかりましたこれを使うんやなぁなんて
おかしいとことは下にこれいかないとダメっぽかったですね
馬鹿か俺は
思え前にアポイントまずをしっかりとは思うねああああ頭切れないと思います
俺そうなんだが大丈夫かあと empower
ん
me
だーっ
k 節減できるさすがに今回はいけるぞあーん
a
[音楽]
re
いや普通死ぬ死ぬ死ぬ本当に行かないんだけどねー6硬すぎ一人でるの辛いなぁ誰か
あぁ
不利なんですよ説明書なかったんだろう何とも言えるのですけど苦痛ネットで調べで
やってる動画たこのを見て手順をやってやってるんですけど
follow キャン古いかも知れません僕には4日つよ俺
カバー
んですあれ
やおやうよおやー
par
んドイツ選んだら女凄いなんかできなくてめっちゃイライラしてブツ切れそうだったん
ですよできました
テンションはこれこれは
大植後はいえばいいん
バーン
ああああああ
矢部山に行きたくなってきた s 5i なぜでちゃんとキャンプな
以外が広い気がしますねまりとは揺らいであれば全然入れますね b なぁ
正面付けてもの入れるポケットもついてますしこれは服にょんでしょ
それに沿って全然前に僕がティの人4入り
武神でれると思いますこれさぁ福田せ俺マスクの中にいいんだぜめっちゃキャンプし
たくなっちゃ
はしないんですけどもさっきのみだわかってもらったと思うんですけど愛ですねテント
を作る工程でねぼくつまずくタイプの人間などぅいてないのかなと思いますよね
うまいとほんとずに作るんですけどこれが僕がインド流の一つかもしれませんサティ
グッズでございまーぬー
me
大
はいというわけでですねこれどう見ても吹くに見えるんですよ
ジェントって結構荷物大きいと思うんですけど今持ってないのに家の言いに行ったら線
とできているドッキリできると思うんですよつづくコスト利点と仕掛けて行きたいと
思いますでは行こうよ
ブチブチブチブチを受理しだって打つ
[音楽]
ています
ん
分かった
の
ています
ん
おん
wh
スーハーわー
[音楽]
えっ
あーちょっと待っていた母
うわぁ
あっ me
me
teame
ana あああっ